I'm a single mother to 4 kids,
and obviously money gets tight and I needed to find extra income.
And this is not some fucking scam.
I'm not gonna sell you shit in this video,
but you can listen if you wanna learn something.
I literally just contacted the Small Business Association for my state.
I live in Colorado. Contacted the Small Business Association,
was like, hey,
I need to do something. They set me up with a counselor,
like a business consultant,
basically,
like a woman who's been in business who can offer me counseling and,
like, resources and stuff.
Hooked up with her and she said, oh,
there's actually this grant going on right now.
If you take these three classes,
will give you 12 dollars
to reimburse you for all the startup costs for your business.
And I was like, shut the fuck up.
So sure enough,
she set me up that day, I took the first class.
The next week, I had another meeting with her,
she set me up for the second class,
I had another meeting with her,
and she set me up for the third class.
And I mean, like a meet,
like, it was like a virtual.
Like, I was in my pajamas.
I was like, hey,
what's up? She was like, okay,
here's the next class. Click through that shit.
And then it gave me money to.
It reimburse me all the costs for, um,
like a business address, like to Get a PO box,
my website, uh,
somebody to build the website,
a computer. So
now all I have to do today
is submit all my receipts for the things that I've paid,
and then the government is gonna give me a grant,
reimbursing me for all that money.
So it cost me zero dollars to start this business.
And pretty soon, I will have my website up and running,
and you'll be able to buy products from it,
and I'll be able to support my family more.
So you don't. It doesn't always have to be scammy.
You don't have to have everything figured out.
You can sometimes just start with a phone call,
start with a question, and see where it leads you.
And I'm, like,
beyond proud of myself. So I wanna encourage you.
You can fucking do it.